>> Laura: THE CONTRAST BETWEEN
BARR AND MUELLER COULD NOT BE
MORE STARK.
JOINING ME NOW, FORMER GOVERNOR
OF ARKANSAS AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR MIKE HUCKABEE AND
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR, AND
AUTHOR OF THE INTRODUCTION FOR
THE MUELLER REPORT, THE FINAL
REPORT OF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
INTO DONALD TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION, ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
PROFESSOR, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
BARR'S RESPONSE?
LOOKED LIKE HE WAS AT A HUNTING
LODGE, TO BOB MUELLER?
>> HE WAS 100% RIGHT.
MUELLER SHOULD'VE COME TO A
CONCLUSION.
I THINK IF HE HAD COME TO A
CONCLUSION, IT WOULD'VE BEEN
THERE WAS NO OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, HE WAS PROBABLY
PRESSURED BY HIS STAFF MEMBERS
NOT TO COME TO THAT CONCLUSION.
HE SPOKE COME TO THAT
CONCLUSION.
I THINK THE ONLY THING MUELLER
SHOULD'VE SAID THAT HE DIDN'T
SAY IS THAT THERE SHOULD
PROBABLY NO LONGER BE ANY
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION WAS
THE FINAL NAIL IN THE COFFIN OF
SPECIAL COUNCILS, SPECIAL
PROSECUTORS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL COULD DO
THIS HIMSELF.
A STAFF PEOPLE, CIVIL SERVANTS,
FULL-TIME PROSECUTORS.
EVERYTHING THAT WAS DONE HERE
COULD'VE BEEN DONE BY THEM.
WHEN THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR, THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL IN THIS CASE
SAYS I COULDN'T INDICT THE
PRESIDENT ANYWAY ACCORDING TO
THE CONSTITUTION, WHAT WAS HIS
INVESTIGATION ALL ABOUT?
AS JUDGE ALICE POINTED OUT IN
THE MANAFORT CASE, THEY WEREN'T
INTERESTED IN MANAFORT, THEY
WERE INTERESTED IN SQUEEZING
MANAFORT AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TURNED OUT THERE WAS NOTHING
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THERE WAS NO ILLEGAL COLLUSION,
NO COLLUSION ANY KIND WITH THE
RUSSIANS AND THE INVESTIGATION
SHOULD HAVE ENDED THE DAY THAT
THE DECISION WAS MADE, BUT IT
CONTINUED ON AND ON WITH
COLLATERAL CRIMES, MANY OF WHICH
WERE NOT EVEN COMMITTED, AND
OTHERS IF THEY WERE COMMITTED
COULD'VE EASILY BEEN PROSECUTED
BY ORDINARY PROSECUTORS.
>> Laura: BINGO.
>> I THINK WILL SEE THE DEATH
KNELL OF THE SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE.
>> Laura: THAT PERFORMANCE BY
MUELLER, I GOT INTO A BIG ROW BY
ONE OF OUR FAVORITES THOUGH
EISENBERG LAST NIGHT BECAUSE HE
THOUGHT, OH, IT WAS FINE FOR HIM
TO MAKE THAT STATEMENT, THE NINE
MINUTE STATEMENT.
THAT WAS FINE.
BUT GOVERNOR HUCKABEE, I THINK
THAT STATEMENT IN IT OF ITSELF
WAS AN INDICATION AS TO WHY THIS
WHOLE SPECIAL COUNSEL STATUTE,
PROVISION THE WAY IT GOES, IT'S
GOT TO BE DONE AWAY WITH.
JUST DO LINE PROSECUTION, BUT
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL ARE ALWAYS
OPENING THE DOOR TO CORRUPTION,
TOBIAS, OR THE CONCERN ABOUT
BIAS.
I DON'T THINK ANY GOOD COMES OUT
OF IT.
I REALLY DON'T.
>> I COULDN'T AGREE MORE WITH
PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ WHO IS
SIMPLY BRILLIANT AND ONE OF THE
THINGS I'VE MOST ADMIRED ABOUT
HIM IS THAT HE'S AN ADMITTED
LIBERAL AND SOMEONE WHO VOTED
FOR HILLARY, BUT HE'S PLAYED
THIS AS A MATTER OF THE RULE OF
LAW AND THE ISSUE OF CIVIL
LIBERTIES, WHICH IS WHAT WE
SHOULD WANT FROM EVERY SINGLE
ATTORNEY, AND CERTAINLY EVERY
LAW PROFESSOR IN THE COUNTRY.
FOR THAT, I OFFER MY SINCERE
APPRECIATION TO ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
HERE IS THE CONTRAST BETWEEN
BARR AND MUELLER.
MUELLER COMES OUT AND SPEAKS FOR
NINE AND A HALF MINUTES, DOES
NOT TAKE A SINGLE QUESTION.
BARR ON THE OTHER HAND SITS DOWN
TO AN INTERVIEW AND TAKES
QUESTIONS.
A HUGE DIFFERENCE IN SOMEBODY
WHO COMES OUT AND SAYS, I'M NOT
GOING TO SAY ANYTHING OTHER THAN
WHAT'S IN THE REPORT, BUT I'M
GOING TO TOSS SOME RED MEAT OVER
TO THE DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS.
FIRST IT'S THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHO SAYS, SURE, I WILL TAKE YOUR
QUESTIONS.
I'VE GOT NOTHING TO FEAR AND
NOTHING TO HIDE.
KEEP IN MIND THAT CONTRAST.
>> THE OTHER THING THAT BARR WAS
RIGHT ABOUT THAT IT'S NOT THE
PROPER ROLE OF SPECIAL COUNSEL
TO SERVE AS AN INVESTIGATED    I
TO SERVE AS AN INVESTIGATED    V
TO SERVE AS AN INVESTIGATED    S
TO SERVE AS AN INVESTIGATED    I
TO SERVE AS AN INVESTIGATED    A
TO SERVE AS AN INVESTIGATED    N
TO SERVE AS AN INVESTIGATED    F
TO SERVE AS AN INVESTIGATED    R
CONGRESS.
HE SHOULD NOT HAVE SAID TWO OF
THE THINGS HE SAID, NUMBER ONE,
IF THE EVIDENCE WOULD'VE SHOWN
HE WAS INNOCENT, WE WOULD'VE
SAID SO, IT'S NOT WHAT THE
PROSECUTOR SAID.
IT'S WHAT COMEY SAID WHEN HE
INDICTED
LET
THE OTHER BRANCH OF THE
GOVERNMENT DO THE INVESTIGATION.
YOU AREN'T THE HANDMAIDEN THAT
SHOULDN'T HAVE SAID ANYTHING.
HE SAID THERE'S TOO LITTLE IN
THE REPORT, DIDN'T COME TO A
CONCLUSION AND TOO MUCH AFTER
THE REPORT.
EVERYTHING HE'S DONE SINCE THE
REPORT CAME OUT HAS BEEN WRONG.
THE REPORT ITSELF, AND WHAT HE
SAID THE OTHER DAY.
I HOPE WE'LL NEVER HEAR ANYMORE
FROM SPECIAL COUNCILS, SPECIAL
PROSECUTORS, THEY DO MUCH MORE
HARM THAN GOOD.
THEY UPSET THE RULE OF LAW.
>> Laura: GENTLEMEN, I'VE GOT
TO POINT THIS OUT, HOUSE
DEMOCRATS NOW HAVE BEEN RAMPING
UP THEIR CAMPAIGN AGAIN SPECIAL
COUNSEL MUELLER TO TESTIFY
PUBLICLY.
LET'S WATCH.
>> BOB MUELLER HAS ONE MORE
SERVICE TO PROVIDE THE COUNTRY,
MUCH AS HE APPEARS RELUCTANT TO
DO SO.
THAT IS HE REALLY SHOULD TESTIFY
BEFORE CONGRESS.
>> HE DOESN'T GET TO DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT HE TESTIFIES
BEFORE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE DOESN'T GET TO DECIDE WHICH
QUESTIONS HE CAN TALK ABOUT.
>> IT'S LIKELY THAT SPECIAL
COUNSEL MUELLER WILL RETURN.
>> HE COULD NOT HAVE BEEN MORE
CLEAR THAT THAT IS IT FOR HIM.
LOOK LIKE HE WAS PASSING A
KIDNEY STONE IN THAT NINE
MINUTES.
CANNOT BE HAPPY TO BE THERE.
THE GOVERNOR, SHOULD HE TESTIFY,
WHOM WITH THAT BENEFIT?
>> I THINK IT WOULD BENEFIT THE
TRUTH.
I THINK FOR THE FIRST TIME, WE
MIGHT GET OUR MONEY'S WORK OUT
OF THE 35 MILLION THAT WE'VE
SPENT.
POP SOME POPCORN, SIT AND LISTEN
TO PEOPLE.
AS FOR BOB MUELLER, WHY DID HE
PICK THE PEOPLE TO SERVE IN THAT
STAFF THAT WERE CLINTON DONORS
AND THE WAS THERE ANY BALANCE,
ANY CONSIDERATION TO GET PEOPLE
WHO ARE COMPLETELY INDEPENDENT
OF A POLITICAL BIAS.
I KNOW ANYONE WHO ARE DELIGHTFUL
TO WATCH, I DON'T THINK
DEMOCRATS WANT BOB MUELLER TO
TESTIFY UNDER OATH, BECAUSE IT
PROBABLY WILL NOT BE GOOD FOR
THEM.
>> I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING FOR
BOTH OF YOU FROM THE OBAMA'S
LONGTIME TRUSTED COMPETENT
VALERIE JARRETT WHO WAS BEING
INTERVIEWED, I THINK, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT'S ON.
BUT BEING INTERVIEWED ON SIRIUS
RADIO.
THIS IS AGAIN A CONVERSATION
ABOUT IS THERE A DOUBLE STANDARD
HERE?
TRUMP MIGHT NOT GET MPH, BUT
WOULD OBAMA BEEN IMPEACHED IF HE
HAD DONE THE SAME THING?
WATCH.
>> IF PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD DONE
HALF OF THE THINGS AND SAID HALF
OF THE THINGS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SAYING, EVEN,
YOU KNOW, AS RECENTLY AS THIS
MORNING, WHAT HE HAD BEEN
IMPEACHED AND HOW LONG DO YOU
THINK IT WOULD'VE
>> ABOUT A NANOSECOND.
I THINK THE STANDARD WOULD'VE
FLIPPED DRAMATICALLY AND THERE'S
NO WAY PRESIDENT OBAMA WOULD'VE
GOTTEN AWAY WITH THIS.
>> Laura: AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
WOULD SAY THAT HE WOULD'VE
GOTTEN AWAY WITH A LOT DURING
THE TIME OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, WHETHER IT'S
FASTER FURIOUS, IRS, TRAILING
REPORTERS, OR THE FISA ABUSE
APPEAL OR LESS,
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> I KNOW VALERIE JARRETT.
SHE'S A VERY DECENT PERSON.
I WORK WITH HER.
AND I MET WITH HER ON NUMEROUS
OCCASIONS DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
OF COURSE OBAMA WOULD HAVE NEVER
BEEN IMPEACHED BECAUSE
IMPEACHMENT IS IMPROPER.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS WOULD'VE
REALIZED, AND THE REPUBLICANS
WOULD REALIZE, YOU DO NOT
IMPEACH ON MAXINE WATERS'
GROUNDS.
MAXINE WATERS SAYS THE GROUNDS
OF IMPEACHMENTS IS WHATEVER
CONGRESS AS IT IS.
THE CONSTITUTION SPECIFIES HIGH
CRIMES AND MISDEMEANORS.
IN OTHER WORDS, THERE MUST BE
HIGH CRIMES TO IMPEACH.
IF PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD DONE WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ALLEGED TO
HAVE DONE, THERE WOULD BE NO
HIGH CRIMES, THERE WOULD BE NO
IMPEACHMENT, THERE WOULDN'T BE
TALK OF IMPEACHMENT.
THIS IS A CLEAR ATTEMPT TO
VIOLATE THE CONSTITUTION IN THE
INTEREST OF ONE PARTY.
IF HILLARY CLINTON HAD BEEN
PRESIDENT AND TRYING TO IMPEACH
HER FOR NONAPPEALABLE OFFENSES,
I WOULD BE MAKING THE SAME
-- THEY WOULD MAKE STATUES OF E
-- THEY WOULD MAKE STATUES OF A
-- THEY WOULD MAKE STATUES OF T
MARTHA'S VINEYARD AND THEY WOULD
INVITE ME TO DINNER PARTIES
BECAUSE I'M CAMPAIGNING THERE
CANDIDATE, HILLARY CLINTON FOR I
WILL ALWAYS STATE THE LAW
OBJECTIVELY, NEUTRALLY AND READ
THE CONSTITUTION THE WAY IT WAS
WRITTEN BY THE FRAMERS.
>> Laura: ALAN LICHTMAN, THE
POLITICAL HISTORIAN -- HE
PREDICTED THE LAST NINE
PRESIDENT, I THINK, INCLUDING
TRUMP'S 2015 VICTORY.
HE EXPLAINS WHY MOST DEMOCRATS
TODAY ARE PUSHING FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
WATCH.
>> TRUMP IS IT IN 2020 UNLESS,
WHAT?
>> UNLESS THE DEMOCRATS GROW A
SPINE AND DO THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY AND MOVE
INTO A IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY, I
THINK THE EVIDENCE WILL SHOW
ULTIMATELY AND IMPEACHMENT.
>> Laura: GOVERNOR, THE ONLY
WAY HE SAYS THAT THEY CAN BEAT
TRUMP IS BASICALLY BY IMPEACHING
HIM.
>> FIRST OF ALL, ONLY 29% OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THINK
IMPEACHMENT IS APPROPRIATE.
EVEN IF THEY THINK IMPEACHMENT
IS A WONDERFUL IDEA, THEN GO FOR
IT.
KNOCK YOURSELVES OUT.
PUT THE EVIDENCE OUT THERE.
IF YOU HONESTLY BELIEVE THAT THE
RESULTS OF THE ELECTION SHOULD
BE OVERTURNED BY IMPEACHMENT,
NOT THE NEXT ELECTION, GO AHEAD
AND HAVE THE GUTS TO DO IT AND
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
IT'S A DISASTER, IT WOULD ENSURE
THE REELECTION OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN 2020.
>> AND ALSO THE CASE WOULD GET
TO THE SUPREME COURT.
IF THEY CONGRESS ADOPTED THE
MAXINE WATERS APPROACH AND TRIED
TO IMPEACH ANY PRESIDENT,
WITHOUT EVIDENCE OF HIGH CRIMES
OR MISDEMEANORS, THE
SUPREME COURT MIGHT VERY WELL
HAVE JURISDICTION TO DECIDE THAT
CASE.
TO COPE FORMER JUSTICES SAID
THAT IN CONCURRING AND
DISSENTING OPINIONS AND I
SUGGESTED THERE MIGHT BE A
MAJORITY TODAY IN THE
SUPREME COURT IF YOU HAVE AN
OVERT ATTEMPTS TO SUBORDINATE
THE CONSTITUTION, SUBVERT THE
CONSTITUTION, AND USED THE
IMPEACHMENT POWER AS A WAY OF
REVERSING AN ELECTION FOR THAT'S
NOT WHAT THE FRAMERS HAD IN
MIND.
EXPLICITLY THAT CONCERN.
>> Laura: ALAN, HOW WOULD IT
GET TO SUPREME COURT?
HOW WOULD IT EVER GET THERE?
>> IF THE PRESIDENT WERE TO BE
IMPEACHED, HIS LAWYERS WOULD
BRING A CASE TO THE
SUPREME COURT SEEKING DISMISSAL
OF THE INDICTMENT, ESSENTIALLY,
DISMISSAL OF THE IMPEACHMENT.
>> Laura: WAIT, WAIT, THEY
DECIDE TO.
IT'S A POLITICAL QUESTION,
THOUGH.
DO YOU THINK JOHN ROBERTS AND
THESE GUYS --
>> NOT AT ALL.
>> Laura: THE FOUR LIBERALS
WOULD SAY THAT?
I'M WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
>> REMEMBER, JOHN ROBERTS
PRESIDES OVER THE TRIAL IN THE
SENATE.
THE FIRST MOTION I WOULD MAKE IS
TO THE CHIEF JUSTICE, SAYING
THAT THIS IMPEACHMENT HAS TO BE
DISMISSED BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
FOLLOW THE TERMS OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
IT'S NOT A POLITICAL QUESTION.
WHEN YOU ARE ASKING JUSTICES OF
THE SUPREME COURT, IT GOES BACK
TO MARBURY VERSUS MADISON.
WHEN CONGRESS ACTS IN VIOLATION
OF THE CONSTITUTION, THE
SUPREME COURT IS THE ULTIMATE
ARBITER.
>> Laura: BOTH OF YOU ARE